احب اذكر بس ال ااه زملاء والمن يشاهدنا
اليوم كيف كنا في ابريل 20 20
وكيف انتقلنا من من تلك الفتره الحرجه
الصعبه
الى ما نحن فيه الان وايضا بمجمل التحديات
اللي تعرضنا لها خلال الثلاث سنوات تقريبا
في الاسواق بشكل عام
وكان منظمين او هذا ما نسال اليه
الاسواق
مثل ما يسوون
معنيين بالبنوك المركزيه
انه ما يهمنا في الاساس هو الحد من
التقلبات ما كان ذلك ممكنا لانه ليس هناك
خدمه افضل للقطاع صناعه البطاقه بشكل عام
البترول الا هو انه يكون عندنا تصور
ومستقبلي اكثر استقرار واقل تقلبات فيه
مما يساهم في تعزيز فرص الاستثمار وتمكين
القطاع في الاستمراريه
وفي انه يكون في موضوع في الرؤيه
المستقبليه وبالتالي يكون معزز لي همم
العمل الجماعي يتوجب يستوجب التوافق
ولذلك من الاساس كنت مازلت وسوف ابقى مصر
على انه اعطاء كل دوله من دول اوبك بلس
سواء كان حجم صغير او كبير حقها فينه
تمارس حقها بانها تكون صاحبه القرار وجزء
من منظومه القرار
وهذا الحقيقه اعنا كثيرا بالبدايه وحتى
الان في ان همم
نعزز من الثقه الداخليه في نفس المنظومه
نفسها بيننا كدول وبين المشاركين في
اوروبا
يكون يحصر الموضوع في يعني تجمع بين كبار
والباقين يكون محيدين لا دار لهم ولا قيمه
ولا اهميه
هذا
وين صغرت بعد يعني
احجام انتاج الدول الا انه كان معزز كبير
لمفهوم الشكل العام الجماعي بانه هناك
توافق في منظم
وهذه التوافق له انعكاسات ايجابيه على
السوق
23 دوله
تشكل انتاج حوالي على حسب الوضع يعني 42
43 مليون برميل كبير منه للتصدير
والحصيتهم في السوق العالميه المصدر من
البترول كبير جدا وهذا اللي ينفعك في
نهايه المطاف لانه اسعار المحليه لا تدخل
في الحسبه انما ما يتم تداوله في الاسواق
الدوليه
والمؤول عليه
والتواجد في الاسواق العالميه ايا كانت
هذه المنطقه ايضا في الاول عليك
مع كل التحديات اللي مريت مرينا فيها واما
احيانا انت تحديات سلبيه من حيث وضعت
الطلب
وحاله الركود اللي سواء الاقتصاديه او
حاله الركود في الحركه مع كوفيت الى ان
انتقلنا الان الى مرحله مختلفه في عام 22
الصين
والجوانب السياسيه ذكرت فيما يتعلق
وضع اوكرانيا ومتدائعيات شكرا
وكل الحقيقه تداعيات سياسيه في المقام
الاول وايضا ما ناتج عن هذا العمل من
اجراءات اما
من جميع الاطراف
شابه في البدايه كثير من الفوضى وهذا امر
كانوا مشاهد
واشوفها الان كثير من التحديات لانه هناك
ما زال حراك سياسي مدفوع
باهداف سياسيه لكنه ايضا
هي ممارسه جديده من المعالجات السياسيه
ولا كل الاقتصاديه لان اعتقد انه اثارها
ان تكون سلبيه من الناحيه الاقتصاديه او
هي مدات
لارضاء جوانب متعدده من حاله عدم اليقين
في الاقتصاد العالم بشكل كلي او حتى في ما
يتعلق
ما اريد ان اصل الله هو في النهايه انه في
كل هذه المراحل
حتى هذه اللحظه
تمكنا في اوبك بلس من التعامل والتعايش مع
كل هذه المتغيرات
وان بدت الان اكثر صعوبه
بسبب التنوع التنوع الان من باب الحصر ولا
اقول من باب يعني
اطفاء شيء من العدم اليقين المفرط او حتى
اطفاء شيء من السلبيه او الاحباط لما يمكن
ان نقوم فيه لكن هو كالاتي الى الان
وان بدت بوادر يعني انفتاح اقتصاد الصيني
نتيجه
الموضوع يحتاج وقت وبيكون فيه تردد واغلاق
في كل الدول العالم
الوضع الاقتصادي العالمي الناشئ عن
الحقيقه افراد في
في منهجيه بعض البنوك المركزيه في
توفير المالي اللي يوفر للسنوات
وعدم التردد في زياده
اسعار الفائده اللي اجت متاخره
والمعالجه متاخره ولانها جت معالجه متاخره
جادت لساره باكثر قوه وباكثر
مازال
البنوك المركزيه الان
يعني
المسيطر عليها هو عمليه تحكيم التضخم ايا
كان كلفه هذه
الاجراءات وان كانت سيكون لها اثار سلبيه
على النمور الاقتصادي العالم انت الان
بالاضافه الى ما هو واقع الان من مواضيع
حضر سقوف اسعار فرضت وكلها حقيقه لم تنتهي
بعد
نتائج واضحه
بعض هذه الاجراءات ما طبق خمسه ديسمبر
من البدايات الان مشاهده انه فيه
حاله عدم يقين في الممارسه في اجراءات
متعدده لم يتم بعد
التثبت منها
وهي عمليه سوفت تستمر في تحسينها او
تعديلها بما يتفق مع
المتطلبات السياسيه اللي اتت من غرض ااا
هذه الادوات انشات لاغراض السياسيه
فمدى قدرتها لتحقيق
الاغراض السياسيه ايضا
لها بعد لم يتضح بعد كذلك رده الفعل من
الجانب الاخر وما يمكن ان يقوم به
وهل ستكون مماثله بما قام به
الطرف الاخر في ما يتعلق بالغاز هل هذه
الممارسات في البترول ستكون مشابهه او
مختلفه هذا ايضا
في كل ما سويناه وهذا اللي ودي اركز عليه
ودي الجميع همم
من باب المكاشفه ومن باب ايضا لمن يسمعنا
خارج هذه الغرفه عن الوطن بس خارج هذا
الوطن
وبلاس تعمل وفق اليه
ومنظور تصاعدي تحت
لا ندخل في جانب سياسيه ولا ندخل في جوانب
التحالفات ولا عندنا
نيه مستقبلا اننا ننتقل باي نقله نوعيه
ايا كانت الا منظور السوق ومنظور الجانب
الاقتصادي
خير دليل على ذلك
ما قامت به المجموعه في اجتماع اكتوبر 5
اكتوبر
مع كل هذه الضغوط اللي ابتدات
من شهر اغسطس
ودي للمتابعين يراجعون تصريح سويته انا 23
اغسطس
واكد فيه على بعض الاوامر الامور الاساسيه
في امل بلاس
واؤكد في انه المنظومه سوف تستمر في اداء
عملها وفقا
الاقتصادي فقط
وما قامت به وسوف تقوم به في عمليه اعاده
استقبال الاسواق اخذ من الاعتبار المعطيات
الاننيه
ما حدث في سبتمبر بدايه اكتوبر وكده هو
عمليه
منظورين مختلفين
عليه
الجانب السياسي لحد ما وايضا
الافراط في عمليه
كما سبق في السابق يعني اذكره الجميع كان
في بدايه الازمه الاوكرانيه كان في من
يقول انه روسيا انخفاض رؤيه انتاج روسيا
سيكون حوالي ثلاثه مليون ثلاثه مليون
في من يقول في سبتمبر انه الطلب لا هذا
قرار خاطئ
وين احنا الان من هو المخطئ احنا في اوبر
كل هذه الامور
جد تعزز من موثوقيه القرار
اخذتها قبل امس في المقال
ابو فيصل بعد الاخوان
ودي لجميع يطلع عليه شرود
هذا لا يغير في عمليه تركيزنا على الجانب
الاقتصادي وبالتالي اذا اخذنا هذا في
الاعتبار
واخذنا ايضا بكل ما تعرضت للمنظمه
والمجموعه من ضغوط في خلال الربع الاخير
هذا
انه ايضا لا يظن في اوف كلانس انها ستغير
توجهاتها وطريقه اداءها واعملها وحرصها
المستقبل خلال السنه القادمه على
المحافظه على السوق
المقام الاول وفي المقام الاخير مواجهه
تحديات الان
لكن اذكره الجميع واطمن الجميع انه كما
عالجنا تحديات اكبر في ظروف اكثر
صعوبه او حتى اما الاجانب اقتصاديه او حتى
لجوانب السياسيه
لن نتردد في المعالجه في وضع الشغل بما
يحافظ على
قدرنا على تنفيذ برامج
لا ننسى عندنا برامج
عندنا رؤيه
ولا ننسى انه الرؤيا لها برامج ولها كيف
هايس ولها مستهدفات وايضا في الاف مؤلفه
من الزملاء والزميلات والعاملين في القطاع
العام والخاص يعملون لتحقيق هذه
المستهدفات
وهذا ايضا تحدي اخر انه نحنا حتى في قطاع
الطاقه كان عندنا هذا الهم الكبير لكن
عندنا
المستهدفات الاكبر اللي تجعلنا حريصين على
ان نوفق بين الجانبين بين المحافظه على
الاسواق
مصادر الدخل الدوله وبين ايضا
تمسكنا في انه لا نقفل الجانب الداخلي
22 22
و24 وما هي ابرز
السياسات الحكوميه حول حواف
القطاع الخاص
لمبادره بقياده المشاريع
يعني زي ما بدك يعني
من ثلاث سنوات وشويه ما في مجال انا اعتقد
في كثير الان قدامي ما في مجال انك يعني
تفرط ببرامج
احنا بالنسبه لنا في الثلاث سنوات في
القطاع الطاقه كان عندنا تركه تركه معروفه
كثير من اخواني يعرف
ذاتي والجلد الجلد ذات واحنا الحقيقه
بحاجه
للجد الذات والنقد الذاتي حتى نقدر
نفوسنا
بدون تخوف وبدون تردد
تشوه اللي كان عندنا على جناها الان في
قطاع يعني
يوجد فيصل يعني لا بد لين اشكر مره ثانيه
على
مساعد
الماليه في موضوع معالجه موضوع قطاع
الكهرباء
والبنيه الاساسيه والبيئه بيئه الماليه
اللي كان يعمل فيها
موضوع المزيج الطاقه برنامج الان
تحت التنفيذ تشوه في قطاع البترول والغاز
كيف لنا ان يكون عندنا طاقه انتاجيه من
الغاز لكن ما عندنا قدره على نقله في
مراكز
مراكز الاستهلاك وانت تعرف هذا الشعب عبد
العزيز يعني اكثر من كده التشوه ما اعرف
عندنا كان غزاره في الانتاج في او عدم
التوزيع اصلا وهذه معالجه الان موضوع
الانرجي مكس
لا اغفر لني اذكر انه من اراده ان يريد ان
يفهم يعني توجهات الطاقه في المملكه يبحث
بحث بسيط على موضوع
اقتصاد الدائره الكربوني
المملكه تتنفذ كل المكونات هذا
الاساسيه الاربعه
لموضوع الاقتصاد الدائره الكربوني
ودي اترك المجال للاخ محمد يشرح بعض
الجوانب اللي يعرفها عن قطاع الكهرباء او
حتى ما سوف نقوم به في عمليه مزيج الطاقه
لانه مهم ادراك انه
يعني نريد ان
نستهلك بترول نستهلك غاز نريد ان نستهلك
مصادر الطاقه الاخرى اللي لنا حتى تنافسيه
عاليه فيها
ونريد ان يكون مبادرين في موضوع
توفير الطاقه المستقبليه لهيدروجين ولنا
ايضا مقومات تجعلنا اكثر قدره على ان نكون
اكبر دوله مصدره للهيدروجين من نوعين
الاخضر والازرق
هذه امور حبائن ومويه منحه من الله سبحانه
عيب علينا انه ما نستفيد منها ولا نعظم
استفادتنا منها وايضا بتكون وسائل لنا في
تعزيز منهجيه تطوير
تنويع مصادر الدخل مثلا على سبيل المثال
عندنا قدرات الان تقنيه ان نحول البترول
الى منتجات بتريكوميه اذا ما احنا قدرنا
في هذا ما نسيبه بدر
عندنا مقومات ان نحول الطاقه المتجدده الى
هيدروجين
ونملك يعني بالركض انه احنا اقل كلفه في
كمون دوله منتجه للطاقه المتجدده نفس
الشيء عندنا يعني